like 95 is more of a move where we can
sorry he said 95 sorry yeah yeah i i i
thought this was sort of
i was worried about queen e2 but then i
think maybe queen a8 is just very strong
nothing else appears to work between a8
does look like the y position is
starting to crumble because allowing
knight to x3 check might just be
end of game and
we can even yeah take an after king h1
take on c7
we're not even giving up that much
material for what looks like like a
genuine mating attack honestly
knight h4 check probably also winning in
that position honestly like like
there's even this just looks horrible
among magnus doesn't go for it plays
queen's ignoring it yeah this is kind of
a very striking passage of play because
knight b6
interesting should have given up this
pawn
okay that
just came back on our screen i don't
know what happened there it was a weird
move no no i draw a great yeah he
probably went roxy seven and claimed the
draw or whatever
or gave yes a pencil the look which is
normally how do things are done